if you don't have good news bad news
raising stakes and and and ticking
clocks on every page of your story your
star is going to be boring will you
watch like the Avengers for example
everyone is super good-looking and no
one say anything about it like oh my god
they're so beautiful no they all in the
story about the concept and they are
involved in it but what we do
differently two things one is we're
gonna probably make the movie you know
if we pick if you win this script script
competition why yeah we're gonna make
your movie you can't replace John
Gielgud with anybody you know usually to
meet someone like this one must go to a
bowling alley you know I'm I'll alert
the media you know it's like this is a
guy that has that delivery that can make
those lines sing with filmmaking when
you really think about it the
fundamentals are you know you need a
camera and you need a setting and then
you need actors to inhabit that setting
and that's really all you need
it's intense to shoot a story like the
one that we did 12 hours a day 14 hours
a day kind of thing and then detach
yourself from it afterwards so I know
that you know when we would fight we
would we would fight and I would carry
over and you know and even even the next
day on set you know we'd have to kind of
have to he'd bring us together we had to
resolve some things maybe from the night
before yeah and it's not in the script
but you just went crazy and attacked the
pirate hmm and in doing that you hit
your head but I couldn't see that so I
just had and if you loo was on the floor
you know crying now that he's so
great wow this is not acting this is
real and then suddenly I could see blood
on the floor any day now yeah this is
all gonna fall apart and the costs will
outweigh the benefits and you'll go get
a real job mm-hmm that still could
happen any moment now yeah I could
happen today yeah so I did this script
which was a u.s. Finland co-production
thing hasn't gotten made probably never
will get made but nonetheless i got paid
and i've never been to finland so i
thought how can i write about how can i
write a movie that takes place in
finland if I've never been there and I
thought tourists have tour supposed to
their their their home videos on YouTube
I look for someone who is going to
challenge you and and and work because I
think a lot of people just want to start
getting work right away which is fine
don't deny it if it comes but you know
not everyone's ready right away and you
just got to really be confident what
you're doing before you start trying to
get everyone to like you what's the
target budget you want to shoot this at
and I will read it and the first thing
I'll say after that is a man you know
Zach what you doing Megan oh yeah this
might close up man that's part of a
producer job I had a call with you we
were like you were you were like days
away from shooting and you needed a
location and we were panicking because
we had 12 locations and
had hadn't locked in anything and we had
this like really honest conversation
about like I just if I drew my car off
the road do you think but maybe the
movie not have to happen if I just drove
my car there's one of those tender
moments and the other thing I think
we're doing differently I'm certain
we're doing that nobody else is doing is
we're engaging the audience right out of
the gate you know most sites they wait
to make the movie and they deal with the
filmmaking side of it and then they hope
that the audience likes it but our
members are going to be our audience so
the people that are voting for the
scripts and the actors and so forth
presumably are going to be our end users
they're gonna watch the movie topeka
desire katika saya masih I'm not gonna I
could feel something about Joshua that
would that would be protective and keep
us safe but I do have to admit that
Joshua is also thought to talk about
myself Josh was also very very brave and
in fact the only person in Indonesia
come to Indonesia who had the courage to
open this up in such an effective way
over such a long time and I sort of felt
that someone who has that courage and
the systematic way of going about things
would have the would also was clearly
thinking about all the risks and would
be able to keep us safe I feel that I
film you don't choose the center film so
much the film chooses you the story
chooses you and when once it chooses you
and you feel you feel that like that
that that's what you have to do either
you don't you're not thinking about
where is whether it's going to be
successful whether it's going to be good
for your career something like that you
just need to tell this story and you
need to give it everything you got and
and it become and just making it becomes
the reward in itself you don't always
right what folks are looking for you
don't always right what folks are
looking for from you and folks aren't
always looking to read anything I think
brands are actually kind of cool now a
lot cooler than they used to be i think
that there's
getting the content creation element to
it so as long as the creators are
staying true to their content and
incorporating the brand rather than
highlighting the brand or making it seem
like it was just for the brand I think
is a cool approach to do it where you
can get a paycheck for yourself you can
get your production funded and also you
could work in the brand placement and my
subtle way rather than hitting your
viewers over the head with it if I can
own it outright I could test it I could
become proficient with it myself I could
try out different lenses and different
filters and different stabilizing
equipment and that's exactly what I did
we got the black magic and you know
after watching lots of reviews for it
and we tried some different lenses and
we did some tests lucky for us there was
another lens that I'd just come on the
market another affordable weekly with
great lens and this was the sigma 18 and
35 millimeter lens the story would be no
fun if there weren't twists and turns
it's so much more fun to get your goal
if it looked like you never were going
to get it the joy is so much sweeter on
the other side of that and so if you
have a really huge disappointment you
should just know that when you do win
it's gonna feel so good that said the
gear the things you use the tools the
hammers and nails they're not used to
that kind of universe so you have to
have a lot of redundancy because things
will fail and you have to be very aware
of the impact if you work something in
the cold a piece of electronic gear and
then you bring it to a warm place
there's going to be condensation inside
so it's like a little rain storm and
your electronics that are designed to
make it stop working at the worst
possible moment I was getting a ton of
acting offers but every single time they
said oh can you come and we can maybe
finalize you next week I would have
given my schedule into the hospital for
my work so and those as you know in the
creative field it's all random calls you
you can't really plan those things you
know director team producer team come
together they say why don't we cast
Kalpana let's call her they call me and
yes oh where am I if you find yourself
the crassness
how do you get back on track like this
suppose you start surfing the internet
yeah yeah is that simple I look at my
bank statements and you know are my
little kids hungry faces and then it
reminds me oh yeah I need to work I
would say it's better to do a little bit
every day than to try and binge right so
just fine you can find an hour every day
that might be a good way to get some
work done yeah the only way you can be
true to the reader i think is to be true
to yourself as a writer so I think if
you I think a good rule of thumb is if
it interests you and you feel really
passionate about it then that's what you
should pursue and tell it and first of
all reported out is as thoroughly as
possible research of this thoroughly as
possible and then write the hell out all
right every day I write more than I ever
did I think that there is an endless
appetite now for writing and so it's not
like I get to eventually a 24-7 kind of
business like every other play tennis
how does that how does that help it it
helps enormously because that whole idea
of how much you think and deliberate in
a game of tennis and I much as pure
instinct so you often play your best
game when you merge strategy with
instinct and it's the same with writing
thank you